This is it
this is the path i started us on
you start something pure something
exciting
yeah but why stop there
our very strength invites
challenge challenge incites conflict
conflict breathes catastrophe
a thing isn't beautiful because it lasts
Welcome back this is going to be my new marvel
phase 4 video chris evans is coming back
is captain america that's right you saw the
announcement this morning he is coming back for
more marvel phase 4 movies in live action and for
some other stuff in the disney plus series so i'll
explain what that is we know about most of it and
then there's some rumors about some other stuff
that i'll talk about during the video too but if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're finally in 2021 we're
finally going to be able to see some actual marvel
movies hopefully in theaters later this year i'm
also doing a disney plus giveaway for memberships
because wandavision is starting later tonight
that's right episodes dropping at midnight so i'll
explain that at the end of the video too but the
big news of the day chris evans is finally coming
back as captain america marvel phase 4 movies
disney plus series deadline broke the news this
morning he's finalizing the details about which
movies exactly in which series it would be for
and which versions of captain america he would be
playing but cap is back the funny thing about this
too is that this is confirmed to be legit this
is actually happening but because chris evans
has gotten so sassy on his twitter account he's
doing that funny marvel thing where they pretend
like they have no idea what's going on what me
coming back i don't know what you're talking about
what do we have here so just to be clear that's
him messing around if you remember they did a
she-hulk announcement tatiana maslany is going
to be their version of she-hulk kevin feige
announced her as the character at the big disney
plus investor meeting but when people asked her
directly she claimed that she was not going to
be that character even though the director of
the series was congratulating her on her twitter
account so even when news like this is real you'll
get a lot of the marvel actors pretending like
it's not real but i i figure a couple years i i
can't stay away i know this obviously raises a
ton of questions about which version of captain
america he's going to be coming back as because
right after avengers end game that was the first
thing that people asked him because he shows up
as old man cap in the avengers end game ending
scene passing the shield to falcon so people are
like are you never going to play captain america
again and very publicly he and robert downey jr
announced their retirement quote-unquote or soft
retirement from the marvel movies so the really
important thing during that interview is that
he said it's never a hard no robert downey jr has
been a little more adamant about what's happening
with the future of the iron man character but i'll
address that too because marvel is also trying to
get him to come back as iron man in future
projects the same way they're trying to get
chris evans to come back it's just that the chris
evans stuff is going to be happening first so the
next big captain america story is actually going
to be during falcon and winter soldier episodes
we're going to see those in march in just a little
while but that's basically continuing the story
from this moment in the avengers end game ending
scene falcon using the shield in what happens next
after this the way anthony mackie explained it
is that he's actually not taking the mantle of
captain america he's still going to be a version
of falcon but he will eventually have the shield
but a lot of the falcon in winter soldier episodes
is a sort of battle for the throne battle for the
shield a bunch of different competing versions of
captain america people who wore the mantle in the
comics they did the same thing in the batman
comics with battle for the cow who is going to
become the next batman but the first big project
that we actually know about him coming back for
most of you probably guessed it already is
the marvel what if episodes because those are
going to be dropping in this summer they're doing
10 episodes of what if during that he be playing
multiple different versions of steve rogers and
captain america it's an animated series so he'd
just be doing the voiceover for those versions
of the character but the very first episode of
that is literally what if captain america became
iron man and what if peggy carter became captain
britain it'll basically be the captain america
first avenger episode of what if like what if
those events turned out differently so you have
chris evans doing the voice of skinny steve rogers
but he winds up wearing an iron man suit built by
howard stark that looks like a giant tank because
this is world war ii then after that captain
america appears in other episodes of what if
and present day is the regular version of captain
america you also have the zombie captain america
version in the marvel zombies episode of what if
which seems like it's based on one of the avengers
movies i believe just given that winter soldier in
this scene has his vibranium arm and his costume
from avengers infinity war and avengers end game
you have to picture chris evans in the booth for
that one give us your best zombie voice after
that is the live action marvel phase 4 movies
and the bigger disney plus series in live action
so the movies that they're saying he's coming back
for would be like him doing the iron man thing
in spider-man homecoming robert downey jr was
really only in that movie for like 10 minutes
the marketing made it seem like it was iron man
homecoming though there were so many memes when
that movie came out but it was just meant to be a
larger avengers guest spot inside a big crossover
movie the most likely marvel phase 4 movie right
now that that would be for is doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness because one of the major
rumors that might wind up coming true is that he
be coming back as an alternate universe version of
captain america in a cameo scene so he'd still
look like the young version of captain america
with the super soldier serum he looked like young
chris evans in present-day but he'd cameo as a
version of the nomad captain america character
from the comics if you don't remember the nomad
character that was just the name that he took
briefly after he stopped being captain america
he grew disillusioned with the government and
didn't want to wear the mantle for a short period
they kind of referenced that in the movies after
captain america civil war at the beginning of
avengers infinity war when they're doing the
caps secret avengers thing and they show up to
save vision and scarlet witch from the black order
you notice he's got the roughed up version of his
old avengers costume the star isn't there the
avengers logos have been removed this was kind
of meant to be a reference to his nomad identity
from the comics when he wasn't wearing the mantle
but if he winds up in doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness we'd see a more literal version of that
a couple years ago when they first announced
the movie kevin feige confirmed that we'd be
seeing alternate versions of major avengers
characters the question is just going to be
which avengers wind up crossing over as alternate
universe versions of themselves there have been so
many rumors about the cast list and yes i have
seen the imdb page no i do not believe that all
these people are actually in the movie anyone can
edit an imdb page and add people to this so don't
assume that all these people are actually in the
movie the other marvel movies he may cross over
during would be like avengers 5 as old man cap and
present day they're not going to reverse or take
back this version of captain america they're not
going to try and throw this under the bus and then
potentially in the disney plus series we'd see him
cameo as part of falcon's story continuing with
the shield in the future and because they're
doing the nick fury avengers secret invasion
disney plus series you have scrolls impersonating
people that's just another place that they can
bring him back for younger captain america stuff
steve rogers you have scrolls impersonating him
briefly so you get to have your young captain
america in present day without walking back
old man cap and everything that happened with that
character it'd be like a version of loki making
himself look like captain america in that funny
thor the dark world scene oh this is much better
costumes a bit much so tight with the confidence
i can feel the righteousness surging hey you
want to have a rousing discussion about
truth honor patriotism god bless them
the other thing the russo brothers and the writers
of avengers end game hinted at was that marvel
might tell the story of captain america returning
the infinity stones in the future at some point
like you actually see him on his mission to return
all the infinity stones and thor's hammer he took
that back to the events of thor of the dark world
and right after this moment here the way the
russos and marvel explained it old man cap just
quietly retires and stays off the radar short term
but in the comics old man cap also winds up
becoming the new nick fury for a brief period
the whole thing with robert downey jr is they're
also trying to get him to come back to do the same
thing as chris evans like provide voice over
role for a lot of the marvel phase four series
so you have the iron man armor wars disney plus
series with war machine that they just announced
they're trying to get him to come back to do some
voice over for that and the iron heart series as
the ai digital version of iron man because he
downloads a version of his consciousness so you
basically get the jarvis version of iron man in
those series so everyone post all your theories
and your predictions for what they do with chris
evans in future marvel movies and robert downey
jr as well coming back as iron man what's going
to happen next because wandavision is releasing
at midnight tonight is my episode 1 and episode
2 video we'll post on friday just like normal
the episode videos will be every friday just
like the mandalorian episodes i did while you
wait for everything click here for that brand
new black panther teaser and learn what's going
on with the story and click here for that brand
new wandavision episode 1 scene in x-men easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!